[Music]
good morning
[Applause]
I'm Susan Hockfield the president of MIT
and I am delighted to welcome you to the
MIT Energy Forum and I can't tell you
how pleased I am to see how many of you
there are here this morning as we kick
off our day-long energy forum which is
the culmination of a year's work by the
Energy Research Council this is an
important day for MIT today the energy
Research Council will outline the ways
that MIT can offer leadership in one of
the most urgent challenges of our time
finding clean affordable energy to power
up the developed and the developing
world of course many of mi t--'s faculty
and students are already at work on
energy issues and producing significant
breakthroughs
however these discrete breakthroughs
will have far more impact as parts of a
coherent answer to the energies problems
of the world one where at great science
and engineering are informed by profound
expertise in economics architecture and
urban planning information technology
political science and management that's
why we established the energy Research
Council last year and asked it to design
an initiative to facilitate
collaboration on this crucial issue
across all of the Institute's five
schools I really have to thank very
deeply everyone who contributed to this
effort and in particular professors Bob
Armstrong and Ernie Moniz who served as
co-chairs and also there are 14
colleagues on the council the council
solicited advice and input from the
entire MIT community and from external
stakeholders they listened to
tentatively and their recommendations
reflect deep knowledge and deep vision
now for Fisher Moniz will talk about the
Energy Initiative itself in just a
moment my role this morning is to take a
step back and tell you why I believe
this is a defining moment in the history
of MIT I want to answer the most three
most basic questions about this call to
action why energy why MIT and why now
the short answer to the question why
energy is popular demand early in my
tenure here I asked faculty members and
students to identify mi t--'s
opportunities and responsibilities in
the decades ahead the issue they spoke
about most frequently by a very wide
margin was energy and they spoke about
it passionately and frankly when a
community as brilliant and diverse as
those at MIT converges on one issue it
would be folly not to heed them however
just as significant as the interest in
energy here at MIT is the interest in
the world beyond MIT for the first time
in a generation the public and our
political leaders have both turned their
attention to the subject energy lies at
the heart of the news of the day let me
give you just a few quick examples just
last week President Bush again spoke of
America's addiction to oil and it's
negative implications for our national
security
few of us can read about Brazil's new
energy independence thanks to ethanol
made from sugarcane without a sense of
envy many Americans are shocked by
gasoline at $3 a gallon we marvel at the
success of Toyota and its hybrid cars
and once again we fear for Detroit's
future business leaders and all of us
worry that the energy needs of China's
exploding economy will impinge on our
own prosperity and finally the
consequences of carbon fueled climate
change are of concern not just to MIT
scientists like Kerry Emanuel but also
to the residents who returned to the
Gulf Coast worried about a future of
increasing weather intensity this may be
one of those rare moments when our
society suddenly looks itself in the
mirror and admits the truth our
comfortable lives are due in large
measure to cheap and abundant fossil
fuels yet we know that we will pay a
steep price if our utilization of those
fuels does not change as a nation
however we've made Seoul
progress on energy in recent decades
that many Americans are simply
fatalistic about the issue the political
promises made in the wake of the oil
crises of the 70s prompted very little
enduring action as a business energy
tends to be enormous Li
capital-intensive
which slows the pace of change to a
generational crawl in fact in the last
few decades we've seen more
transformative advances in the way we
consume music than in the way we consume
energy of course energy is not a single
challenge that can be answered with a
piece of technology as clean appealing
and profitable as an iPod it is three
intertwined challenges each vexing and
complex in its own right the first
involves supply and demand in a
business-as-usual future energy use
worldwide is likely to double by
mid-century driven in part by the
enormous appetite of the developing
economies China alone has been
increasing its energy use by about 10% a
year with profound impacts on energy
markets competition for scarce resources
is increasingly global and we Americans
can no longer assume the ready
availability of cheap fossil fuels far
into the future the world as a whole
needs to develop new sources of energy
and to increase dramatically the
efficiency in which they are used this
leads to the second challenge security
obviously we all understand the risks
that accompany too great a dependence on
foreign energy particularly from
politically unstable parts of the world
we also need to secure extended energy
delivery systems which are vulnerable to
disruption whether from sabotage or from
natural disasters we must remember that
major wars have been fought over access
to scarce resources and our dependence
on oil for transport means growing
prospects for conflict over energy
supply and while there is a renewed
interest in nuclear power as an
alternative to carbon-based fuels we
must answer the questions about the
consequent potential for the
proliferation of nuclear weapons
the third challenge of course is the
environment
how will we meet our increasing demand
for energy without smothering the earth
in greenhouse gases
after all the internal combustion engine
is a brilliant piece of technology until
the price of gasoline Rises so high as
to make alternatives to it economical
it's here to stay we have to look at
improving efficiency in our continuing
use of fossil fuels and possibly
mitigating their impact with large-scale
carbon sequestration at the same time we
clearly have to expand dramatically our
use of technologies that are less carbon
intensive or our carbon free as a
problem energy is Hydra headed
concentrating on one set of fangs while
ignoring the others is hardly a strategy
for self-preservation yet the public
debate on energy has largely focused on
patchwork solutions such as how to lower
the cost of gasoline at the pump in the
short term at MIT starting today we
intend to redirect this debate toward
the entire energy system it's time to
consider measures that will improve the
world's energy infrastructure and energy
mix it's time to support the basic
research that will transform this
infrastructure in the long term and it's
time to make sure that this
infrastructure will suit a rapidly
evolving world so that economic growth
worldwide can help solve our energy
problems rather than exacerbate them
this leads me to my second question why
MIT why are we the right people to lead
this charge obviously no single
institution alone is going to transform
the energy landscape but the unique
character of MIT offers something
important to the equation we believe we
can be a catalyst for a technological
phase shift we have the expertise in
science technology public policy
economics urban design and management to
produce transformational advances we
also have a history of solving problems
across disciplines our forebears wove a
practical mindset into the fabric
this institution an engineering
determination to fix it we were
established as a land-grant University
with an active activist mission to
promote the public good we have long
since proven that when we focus on large
issues of great public importance we are
able to get things done the radiation
laboratory here at MIT played a decisive
role in the Allied victory in World War
two designing over 100 radar systems
used in the war and it established a
successful model for connected science a
collaboration between scientists
industry and the government that
continues today at MIT in the process
the rad lab laid the foundations for
modern electronics this is exactly the
connected model that will help us
address the challenges posed by energy
MIT is also the place where many of the
most important technologists of tomorrow
will be educated by expanding our energy
curriculum we can steer them toward this
challenge clearly given the appetite for
energy in developing economies like
China and India the International nature
of fuel production and estimates that
electricity has yet to reach billions of
people worldwide it is going to take a
global perspective to solve the world's
energy problems this too is an area
where MIT has expertise 10 years ago MIT
joined forces with universities in Japan
Sweden and Switzerland to create the
Alliance for global sustainability a
joint research program focused on
environmentally sound development
worldwide and last year MIT partnered
with the Kuwait Foundation for the
Advancement of Sciences to found a new
center to study the environmental
hydrologic and management issues
surrounding the crucial resources of
petroleum and water as a community we
are also in a unique position to push
forward market-based reforms in energy
not just because of our close
collaborations with industry but also
because of our history of innovation and
entrepreneurship a study a decade ago
estimated that if you added up the
earnings of companies started by MIT
graduates and faculty together they
would represent the 24th largest economy
in the world if you added in the gain
from technologies and innovation simply
in whose development the MIT family
played a significant role it would of
course be far larger now even while we
expect to work closely with industry and
government on this energy initiative
let's not forget how important
universities are to progress of all
kinds our diverse talents and our
position outside of political and
commercial constraints means we can try
things and we can say things that the
other big players in this game may not
be able to we very much hope to be
viewed as an honest broker of energy
solutions and so we arrive at my last
question why now I mentioned earlier
that public and political willingness to
address this problem is as high as it
has been in a generation
climbing oil prices as painful as they
may be in the short term are making the
marketplace more receptive to
transformative technologies than it has
ever been in the past the
entrepreneurial and venture capital
engines created to advance the IT and
biotech revolutions are starting to look
seriously at energy however the news
outside of MIT is not the only reason
that the moment is ripe for MIT to lead
an energy charge there is also the
tremendous hope that is being generated
within MIT by our own promising research
for example nanoscience breakthroughs by
MIT scientists may overcome the major
technological impediment to electric
cars the weight cost and weak
performance of today's batteries
advances in photovoltaics being
developed here could make solar power a
more practical option bio engine by
engineering research here at MIT may
help us create better biofuels as a
substitute for petroleum and
improvements in the technology of
nuclear power plants could help us
reduce co2 emissions on a large scale
these are but a very few
many examples of critical breakthroughs
on the horizon at MIT I firmly believe
that university research and teaching
can transform our use of energy just as
they have transformed our use of
information the results will not just be
a cleaner and a safer world but also a
more prosperous world
professor Robert Solow one of mi t--'s
Nobel Prize winners in economics has
estimated that more than half of
America's economic growth over the last
60 years derives directly from
technological innovation too often
energy transformation has been viewed as
carrying a heavy societal cost in fact
it has the potential for great social
and economic gain it's time for the
field of energy to experience a
flowering of creativity that has not
seen in decades there are tremendous
opportunities here for those who take on
the challenges at MIT we intend to
provide the leadership this critical
issue demands thank you all for coming
today
you